[Music]
i'd like to just read a
short paragraph from a piece in the new
yorker which says wiseman whose career
has ranged from professional magician to
professor of the public understanding of
psychology at the university of
hertfordshire hartfordshire
we talked about this
before we recorded i can't get it
delight in demystifying magic and other
mind deceptions of all the tricks he
demystified during the evening the
audience favorite was called the yale
goal study
and i was wondering if you could
describe that describe the yale goal
study why that why you think that was a
favorite
yeah so that's the
yale motivation study which is this
wonderful thing
which is that the researchers go
apparently from yale i think it's
harvard actually and maybe harvard or
yeah i can't remember which one
university researchers
go to a school they ask kids what you
want to be when you grow up only about
three percent of the kids know what they
want to be they return 20 something
years later and track them down and that
three percent in terms of the income of
the entire cohort they represent about
70 80 percent of the income
i.e is a really good idea to focus young
in terms of financial well-being later
on
so i've read that
great sticking to 59 seconds wonderful
better track down the reference though i
always tried to get to original sources
on papers couldn't find it i asked my
colleagues who work in those kind of
areas they had never read that paper
eventually i figured out and other
people figured out it's never been run
it's a complete myth it's all over the
web it's in many self-development books
it's in lots of talks it doesn't exist
there is no evidence incredible the
focusing that young
has that kind of impact financially and
that's why i mean about the importance
of asking for that that evidence it's
it's astonishing
you know what makes it all the more
astonishing is how specific
the description is of this supposed yell
goal study right in 1953 team of
researchers interview and i'm shortening
here but interviewed graduating seniors
asking them blah blah did they have
specific goals and then they tracked
them down however but 20 years later and
the 3 percent who had specified their
goals had accumulated more personal
wealth than the other 97 combined it's
very specific yes right and the reason
why it's not it's odd is that that's a
longitudinal study and and so tracking
down that group of kids is not going to
be easy that's going to be a well-known
paper you know it's very difficult to
track cohorts over that kind of time
period so i i thought oh
two seconds work to find it and then you
go oh my goodness that's that's that's
just not out there
well you know what happens too very
often more and more so these days with
technology is you have these
sort of recursive self-reinforcing
myths uh for instance i'll give an
example there's this there's this effect
sometimes it's called the wikipedia echo
effect so let's just say someone puts
this example
in
fill in the blank media outlet and they
don't have fact checkers and they don't
really want to do the heavy lifting of
trying to ascertain whether it's true or
not they just assume it's true because
it's all over the internet
and then somebody puts that into
wikipedia with a citation
and then
you can see how suddenly there's this
snowball effect of citation but there's
actually no original work
that proves
or
demonstrates any clear evidence for this
so you find also a lot of factual
inaccuracies
on wikipedia that becomes
self-perpetuating in that way because as
soon as there's one citation then it
encourages other
outlets
to use the same material and on and on
we go on the merry-go-round yeah so yeah
track down if you can those original
sources and i mean often the studies do
exist and you find out that the what
it's like come
the description of it's been passed on
from one person to another and it's been
sharpened up over time so by the end you
get this wonderful study when you book
it back at the original there's nothing
like the study that you're reading about
even if that study did exist so
absolutely yeah that's the importance of
going back to original sources
you